hi i'm halle and i play sky forester
hi i'm chloe and i play jazlyn hi i'm
francia raisa and i play anna
hi i'm emily arluck and i play nomi hi
i'm yara shahidi and i play zoe johnson
what's up my name is sweetie and i play
indigo hey what's up guys i'm trevor
jackson and i play
aaron jackson yo what's up i'm diggy
simmons
and i play doug hey what's up um uh
lucas about and i play luca hey
everybody my name is jordan buhat and i
play
vivec and we are the cast of grown-ish
and we're here with buzzfeed to play
who's who
who's most likely to throw the best
house party trevor 1-1-1
okay okay i would have to say luca
because one time
we were in paris and he was like oh you
should come to this house party
and i thought it was a party in a house
no it was a party under a museum playing
house music
and trevor now i agree with chloe i me
me okay who is most likely to start a
food fight in the cafeteria forever
trevor ever yeah all day
maybe trevor trevor is pretty goofy i
mean i think all the girls like food too
much to throw it
well i feel like the type to like start
it and then go hide and he starts off
and he act like he ain't started at all
though
who is the most likely to skip class to
sleep
that goes to luca again we also have our
actual like bedrooms on set
and so all of us are always napping in
our characters rooms
luca luca honestly both of them yeah
trevor and luca
luca trevor who's most likely to join a
sorority
or a fraternity jordan jordan that's
right
francia would kill it in a sorority she
would become like head honcho really
quickly and i could see trevor
i could see trevor being a cat yes
definitely a catholic i was going to say
jordan i think
jordan jordan would join a fraternity i
feel like jordan
i feel like i feel like i'd fight in a
sorority who's most
like their character hallie lucas luca
luca luca anthony's playing himself but
yeah
you are sassy little hallie and skye
emily and nomi are very similar
in that they're both really chill really
grounded humans
jordan he said jordan
who is least like their character i'd
like to say it's me
i don't feel like i'm zoey probably
i think that's frontier than me and
chloe
she's yeah all over the place like she's
actually the most
like she's focused human being
and to exist who's most likely to not
respond
in the group chat jordan luca never
trevor's
i actually don't think trevor's ever
texted anymore actually yeah let's
describe that for ourselves yeah i think
trevor's never
messaged in our group chat before i have
before
no i don't think you've ever been there
buddy diggy is
somebody because we have a couple like
just regular grownish group chat
it's always like a nice surprise when i
see him respond
always super pleasant he's always like
to like say happy birthday or something
traveling luka
who's most likely to become a viral
meme this season the vet jordan
jordan jordan jordan i think jordan easy
back yeah sorry all day he's a walking
meme
chloe and hallie we've even seen over
quarantine whenever they go live
the amount of funny clips that come out
of that who is the most likely to pull
a prank on set oh that really feels like
all of us trevor yeah trevor's like
the main answer yeah he pranks holly and
i all the time with our vegan food
yeah hallie started crying yeah cause
hallie like was eating a beyond beyond
me and then trevor was like no that's
real
it's real meat it was even me because
hallie was really enjoying it she was
like this is so
good i think yara actually trevor i
actually know yara yeah
because she's smart enough to do like
you have to be smart to prank
who is most likely to forget their lines
forever forever you're right
me sometimes i think ranking it it'd be
me it'd be trevor
luka me and luca maybe
honestly hallie no you know your lines
pretty well
i'd have to say luca and diggy jordan
had moments
who's most likely to give good
relationship advice
emily emily emily good relationship
advice i'd have to say would come from
francia and emily emily
wow emily for sure you're married she's
a veteran who's most likely to stage a
walkout
on campus oh friends
i should say trevor yara maybe yara yara
hands down
who's most likely to spontaneously get a
tattoo
on a night out me left i said leverage
more chatter than this guy okay
come on luca luca or travis well
no but luca plans it out because he has
a specific tattoo
he's not spontaneous yeah trevor luca
easily because he actually gets tattoos
all the time the three tattoos i have
are from his tattoo guy
who's most likely to go on a twitter
rant i wouldn't go on a twitter rant but
i'll write it in a song
real ferociously
who's most likely to laugh during
inappropriate situations
hallie hallie starts crying
luca lucas is actually a good answer too
you have to though come on if you if we
don't laugh at him who's in line it'll
just be dead silence in here we gotta
that's what i'm saying if something's
awkward somebody has to laugh
that's where me and trevor come in
that's our area of expertise thank you
buzzfeed we had the best time figuring
out who's who in the grownish cast
and make sure you watch us on freeform
you